[Music]
i want to say and i've said this to you
many times before
what a sincere thrill it is for me to
have you on the show because i'm such an
enormous fan of yours well i would
really like to repay that compliment
[Laughter]
i really really would
and i hope one day one day
i really would what i really admire
about the show is you've managed to
establish these these uh what they call
running gags these established bits that
you can go back to and the audience
loves them it's clear clear that you
love them and you can always go back to
that comedy well
and really just set that drill in there
and go down there and suck them dry
till they're until they're completely
you know dehydrated and just
used and used and just when you think
there's nothing left
you go back
and i've always wanted to be a part of
one of those
one of those classics it's a great great
analogy a terrific analogy yeah and i
and i chose one and i chose one you
chose one of our build one and wrote a
bit up and i i do
[Applause]
i i prepared my uh very own top 10 list
and uh
yeah this one is a top 10 things conan
o'brien will say to ruin this top 10
list
steve i don't want to ruin this for you
but that is letterman's bit number 10
that's letterman's [ __ ]
so i'm
i'm not kidding steve letterman has been
doing top 10 lists for over 30 years
number nine i'm not kidding steve
letterman has been doing top 10 list for
over 30 years no really you got to stop
this number eight no really you've got
to stop this steve steve
please please
please
[Laughter]
that is kooky man
who the hell is that who the hell is
that and number two okay steve i
appreciate your commitment to this bit i
really do i'm asking you as a friend
please stop doing the top ten list it's
bordering on disrespect for the
letterman why how's it writing
everything i'm saying how are you even
doing that
all right and the number one
the number one bit is okay i'm sorry
we're out of time
we're out of time
[Applause]
[Music]